هذه الصور هي قليل مما تسرب من الجنينه
حاضره اقليم غرب دارفور في السودان
المدينه تشهد منذ اندلاع الازمه السودانيه
اشتباكات على خلفيات عرقيه وقبليه خلفت
كما تقول مصادر الاف القتلى والجرحى صراع
صادم لكنه ليس الاول الذي يشهده الاقليم
وقد لا يكون الاخير فما جرى في دارفور قبل
نحو عقدين كان كفيلا بهز المجتمع الدولي
ويضع الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر البشير
وعددا من قيادات حكمه على قائمه المطلوبين
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اقليم دارفور
الذي عرف بثرواته المتنوعه تميز ايضا
بتنوع قبلي توزع بين ولاياته الاربع ولايه
غرب دارفور وعاصمتها الجنينه تبعد
كيلومترات قليله عن حدود تشاد تقطنها
قبائل اصول افريقيه ابرزها المساليد
والزغاوه والبرنو الى جانب قبائل عربيه
رعويه منها الرزيقات والمسيريه وبني حسين
في شمال دارفور هنالك قبائل الفور التي
سمي الاقليم باسمها وكانت لها سلطنه الفور
حتى اوائل القرن الماضي ومعها قبائل
افريقيه اضافه الى القبائل ذات الاصول
العربيه منها اولاد راشد والزياديه وبني
فضل والرزيقات هنالك ايضا نيالا حاضره
اقليم جنوب دارفور وتمتد فيها قبائل الفور
والمساليت والزغاوه الى جانب امتداد قبائل
عربيه ممثله في الرزياقات والمسيريه وهنا
لابد من الاشاره الى ان دارفور بعقاليمه
الاربعه نصب عليه حاكم واحد هو مني اركم
الناوي من قبيله الزغاوه اقليم دارفور عرف
ايضا بالمواجهات المتكرره في شتى انحاءه
اغلبها بسبب النزاعات بين قبائل المستقره
التي تمتهن الزراعه واخرى عربيه في حال
ترحال دائم بحثا عن المراعي الخصبه حسب
المواسم طرفان نزاع الحالي في غرب دارفور
هي ميليشيات عربيه مدعومه من الدعم السريع
وقبيله المساليد التي لا تمتلك قوه عسكريه
تمثلها على العكس من بقيه قبائل الاقليم
التي امتلكت قوات عسكريه رفعت السلاح في
وجه الحكومه واجبرتها على التوصل لاتفاقات
سلام جاسم محسن العربيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات